look at my brain
it's huge I have the biggest brain on
YouTube
[Music]
PewDiePie he's that guy that's really
smart that's what I know him age he's
the guy that never says bad words I
remember him well I'm about to prove it
the smart part with brain it on this is
the ultimate intellect puzzle game
draw a shape
three stars I mean
it's a hat it's a cowboy hat
idiot make the ball hit the left wall
I thought I was gonna fail a left one
[Music]
so I've edit that out no one can know
how is this
three stars first try nice tilt the
shape to the Rhine
right got it
boom
easy baby game three stars
this has been sold 74 million times
damn I didn't know this game was so
popular okay first try let's go easy
[Music]
stop catching it stop it
three stars I know I'm the greatest only
two balls that's impossible
yeah no yeah
hey
[Music]
this video was brought to you bye
that's right none of you got it right
North VPS
nordvpn greatest VPN you're welcome I
just like to say that nordvpn gets even
better and better and better with new
free improvements added and this latest
one is split tunneling just fire up your
nordvpn and now you can select which
specific apps you want nordvpn to be
running for as you guys know used
nordvpn to protect yourself online other
people can't spy on you and steal
private information we all know this but
now maybe you're playing a game online
or you don't want to run a VPN for it or
you maybe just want to use nordvpn for
your browser or opposite just disable it
for your browser you can now easily
adjust that through split tunneling it's
a really smart and helpful service to
make sure that you're always protected
and there's no inconvenience of turning
on and off your VPN nor VPN has also now
added a website extension so if you want
to run nordvpn directly in your browser
you can now do that as well thank your
nordvpn nor VPN they just keep adding
great features thank you we appreciate
appreciate it and you should thank me
for giving you this link nordvpn.com
PewDiePie because every two-year sign up
deal you receive a huge discount plus
four months for free Double Uni as we
call it in the base
this is the best deal available through
my link use my link only because then
you guaranteed the best available deal
that you can get online for nordvpn
you're welcome say thanks sign up today
I know you guys won't regret it it's an
amazing service that I also used on a
daily basis
all right let's keep going with the
video just kidding click the link
don't ever doubt me three stars every
time it has to be an object inside
that reminds me of that glass water test
where they're like if it's tilted how
does the water go like this everyone
knows it works like that because I'm the
smartest don't ever doubt me in Edgar
don't you ever damn
an object in the small bombs ooh
impossible oh wait that is actually so
harder
[Music]
so smart yeah
lift the ball up the ground what
my brain must be leaking
what is happening to me
there you go there you go
[Music]
easy
oh actually three stars
yeah I knew I was gonna get through
sorry obviously smart as YouTuber never
say bad thing
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes
big rain
[Music]
beautiful
yeah Easy Come on that was baby level
[Music]
oh my God come on
thank you thank you
you count down three seconds what am I
supposed My ultimate combo
thank you how could I beat that
I was at 16 seconds oh does it count to
dry
[Music]
what so
how long you draw it not how long it
takes to I knew that of course because
I'm very smart don't dump me don't doubt
me
don't do it with me either okay already
half of people have fallen off 36 about
a million thousand
go
go yeah
how was that seven second two seconds
how does this game work anyway get the
ball off the stain hmm
beautiful
the claw make an object touch the red
area
yeah
I'm
the greatest my child will be Einstein
in Carson oh God it's one of those
optical illusions where I look at the
do you see
you wouldn't understand your brain is
not Advanced like mine it's okay
just follow and watch carefully I know I
know everyone's sitting here looking at
this why 52 sold this one
I know everyone's sitting here looking
like
no okay you wouldn't three stars every
time Arrow
the whole thing Falls great I didn't
know that Arrow
why does that move that
ball
we must fortifying
yeah ball ball ball let's go ball let's
go ball why
that was so fast
there you go
there you go go ball
come on ball
that's got it
yeah
yeah I love the drawing come on ball
three
[Music]
there it is perfect ball fight three
stars first try as always right same
make the ball touch the right wall just
gotta do a little whip
[Music]
easy
oh the
I knew that
[Music]
[__] I don't think it's gonna fade
or maybe
come on Ball come on Moe
easy
what oh I can only do ah
[Music]
I didn't know that how was I supposed to
know that
come on ball
yeah
[Music]
that was baby level baby Interlink
balance the platform so I need a cube to
be around here
perfect that's actually how I wanted it
I might need it to be a little flat so
it would stay
and it's a little big well flatten the
surface
that's the square radius stop it's
balance it's balance are you joking
screw this game man
it's balance stop stop thank you thank
you
easy easy
oh my favorite the Double Arrow
they're separating they're separated
is that not the task
it's a happy guy
they're separating stop it
[Music]
come on Evangelion yeah
hey
I'm not a joke
again two little angels all you need now
that's just impossible after reading one
oh I got it easy
that'll be cute
I combined science with poetry you're
welcome three stars fall out of the jar
claw just climb baby
[Music]
come on
come on spoon it giant spoon
oh
[Music]
a little smaller spoon come on spoon
come on spoon hell yeah spoon
yeah yeah
spoon spoon
plays an arm oh that's gonna be so
difficult
[Music]
oh come on
oh my god you're kidding me to increase
my aunts
okay there it is
there it is Boom
the four the deformed Fork works every
time see I bet you would never have sold
that one you're welcome
when in doubt claw it out
come on man it's slow but it's beautiful
oh
come on
yes that looks so good
stopping why am I allowed to use two
that's for idiots
[Music]
oh that's perfect how much time damn I
was fast I hit I have to butcher my
beautiful design for the sake of some
arbitrary time limit but that's how it's
done place the ball in The Orange Box
[Music]
hey
too easy man come on
the claw returns
[Music]
Unstoppable come on come on come on ah
too slow
there it is that's a fastball
go let's go
now you might think this one a little
tricky I'll show you super easy he's got
a Boop
it's not the fastest
but I think it will do the job
okay no no go what
[Music]
is that it
is
push it whoa
oh
first right as always people struggle
with this game
come on fine
chopsticks
[Applause]
nothing is too hard for me
[Music]
oh my God holy [__] holy [__] that's
world record baby one shape too that
doesn't count I'm done my brain's so
huge you might explode I was
legitimately fun I ruined my voice thank
you it feels like old school YouTube If
you guys enjoyed smash like subscribe
see you next video bye bye